[Applause]
what's up everybody we're moving
[Laughter]
now we decided to have this conversation
on the podcast
because there's so many layers of
hilarity to this
but um where does it all begin okay
i'm depressed
[Laughter]
oh that makes me so happy to know that
that makes me so happy i am are you
no it wasn't until i got a text from you
he's waiting have you been depressed now
that he knows you're depressed he's way
happier right now and we're gonna take
you up with him but he's also gonna take
you down with us we're going
down with this [ __ ] baby
hold on grace wait what's her name
titanic rose rose whatever that should
have been grace
[ __ ] his name's rose
anyway so um yeah
you know let's hey
let's let's yeah i've never seen
anything like what it is
you know what i mean we out of here
we're moving we're moving all right
okay okay let's lay out the timeline of
events okay timeline of events
uh we have this uh we work our asses off
on netflix we have this amazing
uh reception to netflix special
everything's awesome
i go to uh hawaii i go on this amazing
vacation
everything's great i know the the
depression is gonna come
oh you're aware of it oh yeah every time
there's like you have this like uh you
know
monumental uh achievement in your life
it could be you're in high school and
you're
you know training for a marathon or
something like that or a race and then
you finally win the race afterwards
you're like
down for a little bit you know just part
of it there's ups and downs see
you like um your happiness all the
happiness you're feeling in that moment
it's almost like drugs right it's like
taking like a lease
on that happiness for you know from
tomorrow or whatever so i gobbled up all
that happiness and now i gotta pay the
piper and that's fine
is what it is doing my best you know my
girl said that we had a whole
conversation i was asking her about like
real deep
stuff that happened to her and like her
family her life and she said
i've never seen anybody less
expressionless
during a traumatic conversation
that's the expression just like this
word that horrible thing happened it's
like akash when you said you almost
drowned
whoa whoa
let's see what this story is about then
when he said it i was like son you
almost drowned
no you said that's wild bro no the first
time you didn't care yeah
yeah almost died
does that sound like some [ __ ] he would
say on the way here you almost died
a [ __ ] truck honked his horn at me so
that's a good ass boy that's why i was
like that's wild let's hear the story
before i give him emotion
yeah then afterward i was like this
[ __ ] really almost died
and then you had no emotion to give yeah
i was out bro
after this week i'm so happy i'm so
happy i gave you nothing
i wish i did pay for the gifts like a
fraternity
you know it's funny what was he just
saying about gifts in indian culture
oh yeah so he was saying that when you
give gifts to someone in money you don't
give them
you only give them an odd values ah is
zero
odd in india do you think if you had to
guess it would be odd
yeah okay that's convenient just making
sure you're being consistent
okay man i am who i am [ __ ] okay
so look um i went out to dinner socks
what how do you give socks socks i think
it's monetary value
i don't think you give someone three
socks if that's what you're saying all
[Laughter]
right
oh you could be right yeah
you can't possibly give socks that's a
good ass point
whoa we figured it out no
that's why other kids are born with
extra limbs and [ __ ]
yes oh my lord
just tear you apart like this when we're
moving why would i get four pairs of
jeans guys he's right
but how are you gonna talk [ __ ] when
i'm like trump storming the capitol i'm
like we have to make a power move
okay new york is shut down there's
nothing we can do we have to be powerful
we have to show strength
we're gonna demonstrate on the beaches
of miami
i finished your stupid [ __ ] story you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] loser so
we go i go out to dinner right first of
all you can't find any place out dinner
there's barbarians
it's barbarians people are it's barbaric
they're barbarians
bro i was biking i'm biking on my
motorcycle
right my huck motorcycle this electric
and got pedals but it's a motorcycle
okay it's fire as [ __ ] yeah on first and
second gear i don't even [ __ ] with the
third gear this is way too quick turbo i
said that turbo is crazy you don't want
to burn the street
when i release the gov if i gotta pass
somebody and i hit that no governor
button
the s the city makes you repave the
roads you [ __ ] tear up it's like
it's worn up it's like gone in 60
seconds where he hits the nitro nitro
out we out of here eleanor i call her
eleanor
i'll call her eleanor bro that's what it
is it's that gt cobra
okay that's shelby this is four verse
ferrari that's what huck's like he's got
that nas on it
i do have it bro do you see the schnoz i
got the shot
all right ready
just pile on while i'm [ __ ] suicidal
we're having too much fun maybe we
should stay
okay so we're riding around i'm seeing
people that are eating out in the cold
it's 30 degrees
yeah this was during the day we were
just riding around seeing like where are
people eating breakfast like what's
going on
they're eating out in the cold people
are getting soup their soup is getting
cold on the way
right they're actually eating like hot
soup tortilla soup it's getting cold on
the way to the table
they're sitting out there freezing right
i'm like what the [ __ ] this is barbaric
go home
i'm literally just telling people go
home while i'm on the bike because i can
go this is saturday right this is
saturday right
we decided to go out to dinner and i'm
asking my boy laurent who got all these
connects he's got like this
concierge service you know shout out to
laurent i should remember the name of
your service so i could promote it but
i'm gonna figure that out
check out baud group b-a-u-d group
that's my boil around so
and you usually can do a connect you
know for i'm like where can we eat
outside
and like everything was booked that had
like a decent outside mm-hmm
we ended up going to la skeena you know
that mexican spot last year maybe
yeah they did their best
but you're still freezing they're eat
you're eating like 40
50 degrees right they got a little
[ __ ] heat lamp on top of you like
you're a lizard and you're just sitting
there freezing your [ __ ] ass off
eating tacos
i'm like what is going on i'm like the
no
indoor dining to anybody's listening
there's no indoor dining in new york
right
it stole the soul of the city yeah
especially in the winter in the summer
we're fine in the fall we're fine in the
spring we're fine
you can walk around you can go to parks
you can do things new york
when it gets cold cold is in it in
uninhabitable it's uninhabitable
it gets too cold to survive outside you
will die if you're outside
you can't just walk around you will die
you need a heavy ass jacket
if you're homeless you need to go into
the subway like if you are outside in
the street it gets that cold
so what do we do we would have these
amazing bars restaurants
nightclubs there'd be all these things
we could go to where we could
communicate with each other
we could be around each other we could
feel that like that cultural
i don't even like calling it a melting
pot it's like [ __ ] um pinball
you know you see these different
cultures smashing into each other you
create these amazing places and it's
just like
it makes the most amazing city in the
world the second you take away
indoor anything you killed it you kill
the soul of the city we should storm
we don't pinball because we're here and
then de blasio we should storm them
we should storm them bro it's
unbelievable you killed it you took away
the soul
yeah there's no pinball because we're
not out exactly it's all inside
well we went looking at the pinball
machine there's no exactly
what is pinball without the whatever
it's those stupid kids they played it
jacks marbles marbles yeah we don't want
to play marbles
the point is we're out here and i'm i'm
literally just going like oh my god like
we went for a walk my girl and i went
for a walk we're like when we get cold
we'll pop into a store
nothing bro yeah in order to go into
[ __ ] north face
there's a 20-person line yeah because
everything's socially disinside you've
crippled being able to be outside
now you're locked into you're
essentially now we're back in quarantine
it's no different in terms of our
ability to operate we can go out to go
to the supermarket but then we're back
inside and being outside is too [ __ ]
cold to do anything
you've killed the city yeah so we're
moving to miami
so i got this idea
i was like why don't we look into
when can i tell my side though this is
this is for the listeners also this is
the first time we've ever heard this
plan
oh yeah this is the first time
everybody's heard this we decided to
talk about here so
i start going what if we just went for
january february march right we're gonna
start
i guess we should tell people now we're
gonna start hitting the road again doing
a stand-up again in march
um it'll be cool we'll announce those
dates and that kind of stuff get that
back
going but we would january february
march we went down south to places that
are actually
open where we could live life and we
could enjoy
obviously nicer weather but more
importantly enjoy like being around
people enjoy going to a restaurant you
know like that's how we [ __ ]
socialize right
and we do that for the next few months
and by the time april comes around
it's warm enough to live with these
unrealistic expectations
that the [ __ ] [ __ ] uh politicians
of new york city have put on us
april we can eat april we can do this so
i tell the guys
i text you all what do you think you
know austin
or florida i actually talk myself into
being on board with either and i think
it's good that you're doing this
i think you got to follow the people
that lead the way for you and i think
this is a great move
either place because you're basically
just doing what joe arry seinfeld did
i love that new york i love this city
new york will never die i will never i
love it
turns out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that was really good just trying to
figure out how to buy it
i really am i really am the restaurants
are down
my fancy restaurants anymore
yo seinfeld had a point okay we gotta
agree
i got the most feeling
literally one restaurant
[Laughter]
[Applause]
seinfeld said i'm never leaving new york
while he left new york
um i said i'm not leaving new york
yeah yeah i'm never and then that [ __ ]
got cold and then now
and the i hey it is what it is it's a
different thing
i am leaving yeah i'm saying i'm going
on vacation i can't go on vacation
for two months what's the deal with
leaving
you're not leaving unfortunately there's
not a lot of deal shit's really
expensive
in boston right now i've been airbnb in
the last couple months
oh my god no but but in all seriousness
that is hypocritical of me
and it is what it is it is what it is at
times sometimes you got to be a
hypocrite
so you can provide for your family
he has two young dogs that are trying to
provide fine dining for my family i need
a yard yeah
nah but you know what's crazy about the
fine dining [ __ ] this should drive me
[ __ ] crazy you know that
museums are open in new york don't even
get me started
i [ __ ] up so bad this weekend what
happened so i planned a whole day with
my girl okay i went through this whole
all the stages of grief that you went
through i was like oh this is gonna be
the perfect weekend
it's gonna be awesome saturday night we
went to like a little dinner and i was
like yo sunday night is gonna be the day
we're gonna like
this is what i had planned we're gonna
go to the met you know and at like four
o'clock we're gonna hang there until
like maybe seven
then we're gonna go get dinner it's
gonna be like a perfect day we're gonna
spend the whole day in the city
so we get to the met i was like i don't
want to spend three hours at the mess so
let's just go there maybe a little late
our reservation was for four because you
have to like book tickets by time yeah
so we get there at 4 30 we're hanging
out we're going through the samurai
exhibit
all of a sudden the guy in the back goes
ladies and gentlemen start making your
way to the exit because we are closed
and i had to leave at five because you
didn't take a half hour
barely a half hour which is really more
than enough
yeah right yeah that's just the place
you heat up why are you
doing this bro it's just painting well
our reservation is now it's [ __ ]
7 30 brother look look thank you
all right okay
we wanted to see egypt and scotland not
scotland yeah they have a medieval
highlander now you're in
oh cool we might have to stay in new
york
in all seriousness so then we [ __ ] up
so we had to leave a five and i was like
all right let's just go find a coffee
shop and we'll wait there until our
dinner reservation for two and a half
hours
oh we had to [ __ ] eat a hot dog out
of stand
that's what we did unbelievable and we
stood out and then i was like oh how
cold is it really
you know what i mean i could withstand
some cold oh can you a minute
30 minutes an hour
freezing cold freezing cold and then
when you go eat dinner you're also
freezing cold yep
you can't exist outside yep it's
unbelievable you can't go
inside for a little break from the cold
yep
they should be shot bro
you